[Music]
if you have a question or comment for
our podcast give us a call 406
219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcasts at
theminimalists.com let us know that
you're a private podcast subscriber so
we can prioritize your message it looks
like martino from princeton new jersey
has a question for us how do you forgive
yourself for wasting time on stuff
currently i'm in my early 30s and even
though i'm grateful that i'm learning
this lesson now and changing my life
i still feel guilty that i wasted my 20s
on buying stuff organizing it cleaning
rather than spending that time on things
and people that actually mattered to me
where do you want to start here ryan tk
yeah i don't know i mean
um
god i try not to beat myself up like
beating beating myself up like
because this doesn't sound like guilt it
sounds like shame to me
and i think that's what shame does shame
will um
take you out of the present moment it'll
make you feel like you're somebody who
you're not it'll make you it will it
could make you feel guilty i guess but
for me it's it's about
just i've never found any reason to beat
myself up with the the the thing that
helps me the best is when i behave
differently so like for for example um
when ryan and i were first together
um i
definitely um
would i mean would rage in the sense of
like um not being patient with her and
uh just just you know not being the best
partner that i could possibly be
um
and
then after that what happened i'd feel
guilty about it like wow like why why
can't i just be compassionate towards
mariah you know even if i'm mad like i
should still show her compassion and i
would beat myself up so
now
instead of beating myself up like i
behaved like the best way to tell her
sorry
is to like treat her very kindly and
lovingly and like that's what i go out
of my way to do
so with this
with with martina's question here stop
stop i mean i'm giving you you're i'm
giving you permission to stop beating
yourself up but like the way you're
gonna feel better and like be able to
forgive yourself and move past it is if
your actions are now in alignment with
what you truly value and what you
believe like just act in accordance to
the life that you want to live and that
guilt and especially that shame like it
will start to it will start to fade but
holding on to it and like i mean it
makes me think of uh what do they call
it uh uh
in the da vinci code where the guy's
like bashing himself you know like it's
there's like there's like there's like
this pr religious practice of like
hurting yourself and somehow this is
virtuous because
you're causing yourself pain i mean this
is a
much smaller sample of that practice
um but
regardless of how big that practice is
if you're using it i don't think that's
beneficial i don't think that is ever
beneficial to just cause yourself pain
that's not virtuous it's not virtuous at
all even even the aesthetics would do
that as well they would often
when they've deprived themselves of
every pleasure
they started turning toward pain
sleeping on
broken glass or wow
stepping on sharp nails and in order to
maybe appreciate the natural state in a
way and i think maybe temporarily that
can help someone but that path
of straight-up masochism
doesn't lead to a more enriched
fulfilling life the same way that
hedonism doesn't right
this is a problem that i call the
problem of the hypothetical demon
where you compare your actual pass to a
hypothetical pass
which
if you had chosen would have made you
happier
and the problem with that is first of
all you don't know that
because even if you had chosen the
hypothetical pass there would just be
another hypothetical that you could then
compare that to and think oh i would
have been happier with that there's
literally no choice you can make that
won't be haunted by the hypothetical
demon because the hypothetical demon can
always say you could have dated a
different person you could have went to
a different school you could have moved
to a different state you could have
accepted a different job and maybe you
would have had even more happiness than
you have now and you have to recognize
that that's an illusion the reason
you're able to look back on your past
and judge it the way you are
is because you have wisdom now and that
wisdom has come to you through the
choices that you made at a time when you
were working with the best information
that you had you didn't know then what
you know today and the way that you got
here is by being true to who you were at
the time you can't alter that you
embrace that wisdom that you have and
move forward with that
something to make it a little bit
non-academic and personal
i went home to chicago once a few years
back to celebrate a birthday and there's
a close friend that i have there and i
tried to hook up with them and we texted
each other back and forth a little bit
and it just started to feel complicated
like we could make it work and i was
like don't worry about it man we'll get
together we'll get together next time
shortly after that he passed away
and
i beat myself up over there for a long
time and said ah i made the wrong
decision i should have
done that thing
now had i done that thing i would have
enjoyed that time with him and i'm sure
i would have been happy
but i don't know if i would possess the
sense of urgency that i have now about
making time for friends when they're in
town or when i'm in town if i would have
chosen that path i would have had a good
time and i would have been thankful that
i had that good time as a result of how
things have transpired now
if i got somebody that i love i'm not
going to let the opportunity pass
without telling them that if i get a
chance to be with somebody i'm not going
to take for granted that i'll have that
chance again tomorrow so the wisdom that
we have today is the result of the
person that we become by being true to
who we are at each given moment in time
and then experiencing
the knowledge that can only come from
experience there's always going to be a
hypothetical past you can't go back and
do that you've got to
let go of what's already transpired and
embrace the wisdom that you have now by
the way to forgive is
to let go
to let go of future trauma that's caused
by clinging because really what you're
doing with the past past exists only in
the present moment it is always now i
know that is a hindu or buddhist cliche
at this point
but there's a hyper truth
within this because the past and the
future both occur in the present moment
and so yeah we're holding on clinging
to that past
and it causes trauma in your future as
you continue to drag it into now and now
and now and tomorrow's now and next
week's now and so what's happening here
for martina is
she's holding on to that and it's
causing trauma
now how do you how do you let go you
forgive you forgive
yourself
and how do you forgive yourself well you
might have to even apologize to yourself
martine i'm gonna send you a copy of our
book
love people use things there's an entire
section in there about apologizing to
others apologizing to yourself and sort
of the power of apologizing so if you
enjoy our podcast i think you'll enjoy
the audiobook version of love people use
things or if you want the book book or
the ebook version i'll be happy to send
those to you as well joshua liked this
quote i heard patrice washington say
forgiveness is letting go of the idea of
a better past
dig it yes because you can't relitigate
that pass
you can simply
let it go
because this didn't happen
to me as my mom said this happened did
you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
theminimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free
[Music]